i enjoyed the competition no doubt
but i think i enjoyed the competition
with
my friends i didn't play the individual
sports i i just love the camaraderie i
love
being next to your teammate picking them
up when they fall down getting picked up
when you get knocked down
and i think i'm realizing now that a lot
of what i loved about the sports
was just the journey that you have with
the other teammates
doesn't matter who we're playing like
we're just gonna go out there and we're
gonna play hard
my dad being african he's from west
africa
and you know he's a negotiator because
you know if you go to any of those
kind of second third world countries
there's there's bizarre as you can go in
and negotiate
so we're sitting in front of coach dave
dye after
we have our kind of recruiting trip and
he sits down and coach dies like we want
you
what's it gonna take to get you here and
my dad
straight up full scholarship right
and uh and coach dye says yes and we
played
big big schools we played grand valley
played saginaw
wayne state 15 000 students 20 000
students and we've got 1500 students
right so we're going into battle with
with some pretty big teams i'll never
forget my sophomore year
we're playing ashland and it's a tough
game it's it's a
it's a night game it's under the lights
we're in the fourth quarter we're coming
down
and we're we're behind they're on the
seven yard line and they're driving
they're getting ready to go in the end
zone
our outside line middle linebacker
blitzes and he hits the quarterback
right when he's releasing a pass i'm
able to step in front of it
and run a pick six back to the end zone
you know 93 yards
and literally that win you know wins the
game for me it was not about
it wasn't about me getting the accolade
it was about us
winning together you know it was a game
against wayne state
i set some records i had four
interceptions and a punt return for a
touchdown but we lost that game
i cried i mean as a college football
player i remember in the locker room
just like
[Music]
it doesn't matter what records what we
lost the game
i was learning a little bit of what it
what does it look like to not
to not win and to have to work and fight
through that
we didn't play for championships we we
just
we went out there and played hard
you can't really say enough like like
what what god
and and my walk with jesus how it's
impacted me
it was amazing to see the ways in which
hillsdale
invested in that as i look back now like
i bet he was praying for me i know she
was praying for my wife
i think to myself like there's there's
so many people
that had an impact and had input and and
made a
a huge huge investment in me i never
would have thought that hillsdale would
have the impact that it did on me
and uh ironically i you know i didn't go
there because it was a conservative
school i didn't go there because it was
you know i necessarily held the
principles that hillsdale stood for
but being there
helped me understand the importance of
those things if you asked me what your
dream was
growing up as a kid it wasn't the major
leagues or the nba or the nfl it was
really to have a family
you know and so i can honestly say that
i'm living my dream